[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
among playful carefree children
everywhere are the future rulers of a
very troubled world
children are the greatest of our
possessions our most treasured riches
upon them rest the hopes of civilization
upon their training depends the whole
order of the world's affairs
it is for children that we live work and
have our being by divine command
since the beginning of time health has
been mankind's greatest desire and goal
it stands first in importance among
those things which make for a long and
complete life
more to be desired than great wealth
honor or high position
the race belongs to the strong
other things being equal those with the
bounding health are the ones who survive
and command
to be a good doctor minister teacher or
other leader in any walk of life
a boy or girl must have good health and
guard it carefully as the most precious
of all their possessions
we know now that many of the ills of
humanity including those which arise
from defects of the teeth and which
cause much physical and mental anguish
can be prevented
such prevention calls for the adoption
of a sound program of health in early
life
and the persistent practice of good
health habits every day of the year
this film the life of a healthy child
shows how easy it is to order one's
daily habits to have a long and healthy
life
let's spend the day with a healthy child
it's seven o'clock and this little girl
has had 10 to 12 hours of sound
refreshing sleep the first morning chore
is to drink a full glass of water every
day a child should drink four to six
glasses of water
next the hands and face are thoroughly
washed with plenty of good soap and
water this should be done at least twice
a day as cleanliness as nature's best
beauty treatment and the only cure for
many of the sores which appear on the
face
clean and sound teeth are even more
vital to good health
use a good small brush with short
bristles so that every part of the back
piece may be released
plenty of good dental cream or powder
ask your dentist to show you the right
way to brush your teeth brush from the
gums toward the biting surface use the
brush as dry as possible wetting it just
a little at the beginning
brush the biting surfaces press the
bristles well into the groove brush the
outside of the upper back piece go way
up and brush down toward the biting edge
brush the outside of the lower back
piece scrub hard
brush the inside of the upper back piece
from the gums down
force the bristles in between the teeth
brush the inside of the lower back key
reach way down and brush up toward the
biting edge
then brush the upper front teeth inside
and out with a lengthwise motion of the
brush
now brush the lower front piece inside
and out brush vigorously to polish the
piece and toughen the gum
when finished with the teeth brush the
inside of the cheeks the gums and tongue
this will stimulate all the mouth
stitches
finally while cleaning and putting away
your brush take water into the mouth and
force the cream studs in between the
teeth and all around the mouth your
mouth will then feel clean and be clean
if your parents and physician prescribe
cod liver oil learn to take it with a
smile
good health demands such wholesome and
inexpensive foods as bread leafy
vegetables all kinds of fruit eggs milk
butter cream and ice cream
this morning for breakfast we shall have
sweet and juicy sliced oranges
a cooked
cereal an egg
all wheat toast with plenty of butter
and a glass of rich delicious milk just
the right kind of a breakfast for the
school and play activities of the day
and now it's time for school
walking wrecks shoulders back feet flat
on the pavement
breathe deeply of the fresh morning air
through the nose with the lips closed
continual breathing through the mouth
will deform the bones of the face which
can only be corrected by an operation
cross street only at the safety lane
never run across the street when it
plays it may cost you your life or maim
you for life
wait for the cars to pass and then cross
and safety if all children will follow
simple safety rules parents and teachers
would be spared one of their greatest
worries and countless lives would be
saved
in school sit erect with the feet flat
on the floor never slouch in the seat or
hunch the shoulders
an incorrect sitting posture at school
has ruined many a child's form
if you get the habit of sitting up
straight you will develop a good form
and a pleasing personality which goes
with it
every child should have plenty of
outdoor exercise for a healthy body and
a contented mind no matter what part you
play in the game play it with a vest and
a smile
practice the art of good sportsmanship
learn to be friendly and you will
attract friends but it's time for lunch
and all who are in good health should be
hungry when the hour arrives for the
midday meal a sensible luncheon consists
of a soup
vegetable salad of raw tomatoes raw
cabbage lettuce and celery
whole wheat bread spread well with
butter
a small helping of pudding
and
a glass of milk
vegetables are best if eaten raw
it is never wise to exercise too
violently immediately after eating
long dancing is a mild form of exercise
good for the growing girls it develops a
graceful body poise of mind and a
cooperative spirit
skipping the rope calls for a quick eye
on nimble feet while simple gymnastics
develop muscular skill
swimming is a particularly fine sport
for boys and girls who want to become
strong men and women
every child should learn to swim not
only for health but for safety
in play as in school practice correct
habits of standing sitting and walking
if you have formed those habits they
will come naturally to you all through
life and help you to have a fine disease
try it and see
and so the day goes on with other forms
of helpful place so necessary to every
child for a normal healthy and happy
existence but even with the best of
physical habits every child should have
a health examination at least once a
year
and so today the parents of this little
girl have wisely centered to their
family physician
after visiting with her and asking
questions about her health the doctor
has to change the lighter garments to be
weighed and measured
for if a child is much under or
overweight something is wrong that needs
attention
the eyes are tested poor eyesight often
causes the child to be irritable and
backward in school the food is examined
for soreness or enlarged tonsils which
will cause a child much trouble
nasal and sinus infection often occurs
in childhood proper treatment will
correct it
running or sore ears should never be
neglected if ignored they may lead to
intense pain and serious illness
heart trouble and tuberculosis often
make their start in childhood
they can be prevented or cured in the
early stages once the disease has become
established the treatment is long and
tedious
a yearly examination will reveal defects
before any great damage has occurred
and as a final precaution every child
should have the tuberculin test be
vaccinated against smallpox and
immunized against this area
the next step in this busy day is a
visit to the dentist which should be
made at least twice a year
soaring decayed teeth prevents the
chewing of the hard food
abscess teeth discharge plus into the
system the fatality is lowered and
disease is invited a dental examination
will reveal the defect and all such
pieces should be promptly filled or
expected
x-rays are valuable in discovering
hidden defects and infections which may
cause much trouble in later life
returning home the healthy child enters
cheerfully into the spirit of the family
circle and plays contentedly without
complaints
even a pets love a kind word and
cheerful smile and forget their
differences while they ramp and eat
the healthy child who eats no sweets
between meals is always ready for dinner
this should be a happy occasion as an
age of digestion tonight we should have
meat peas spinach potatoes
followed by a fruit salad a couple
slices of whole wheat bread with plenty
of butter
ice cream or fresh fruit
graham crackers and milk
if there is evening studying to do be
sure the light is in proper position
otherwise you may weaken and ruin your
eyes
and so the day draws to a close once
more the teeth are thoroughly brushed
before going to bed
apply yourself vigorously to the past
taking 20 strokes on each surface
brush tops of upper and tops of lower
teeth brush outside of uppers and
outside of lowers brush inside of uppers
and inside of lowers brush hard pressing
bristles in between the teeth
brush the front upper and lower inside
and outside
brush gums peaks and tongue for
stimulating effects then while washing
and putting your brush away take water
and force the cream sludge in between
the teeth and all around the mouth
an evening bath at the end of an active
day or at least twice a week
and now it's eight o'clock time for all
healthy children to be in bed
sleep with wind is up winter and summer
it is the end of a healthful and happy
day
and so good night
[Music]
you